listen I have a million questions for
you and um I want to say thank you so
much for making me laugh with the Ted
show but you know I'm a huge fan of the
Orville and I need to ask you um is it
over it will there could there be more
could there be like a TV movie like what
what can fans hope for it is not
officially over yet no okay thank you
that's that's better than you telling me
it's all done you know um so one of the
things that I really love about your
work and especially it's true in Ted is
that everyone seems to be so timid to
rock the boat with a joke and one of the
things about Ted is he says and does
things on the series that I would say
are you know pushing the boundaries or
inappropriate so can you sort of talk
about doing that with the show and maybe
why is everyone so nervous about making
jokes that might offend people I think
there's there's there's two reasons one
that's very specific to Ted and to shows
like Family Guy uh yeah you're you're
right there there is a there's an
absence of
Flatout hard comedy these days a comedy
that's just out to get laughs that's
that's out
to explore the boundaries of of the
genre and see see if there's an edge
that uh that takes it too far and it's
kind of fun to
to to find where that edge is and make
sure you don't go past it but to go
right up to the
and um I I I think in many
cases uh where I have a little bit more
of a safety net is that if you're a
stand-up comic or if you are somebody
who is the face of their
show every week then you are if if you
screw up and and if you if you have a
joke that that goes too far for people
uh yeah you you you're you're going to
be the one who gets attacked with Family
Guy and with
Ted first of all these are animated
characters um it
it's you know Ted does not exist Peter
Griffin doesn't exist you can't tweet at
him uh and in terms of the show like
people are smart enough to know look
it's a lot of people that have to get
together and and
decide uh what goes on the air a
television is very much a group effort
and people are Savvy at this point they
know that and and so for me it kind of
it kind of protects me in a way that
that
maybe gives me a little bit of an unfair
Advantage because these are animated
characters but I don't know that's
that's just that's just one Theory I I I
think I think people are a
lot more able to
distinguish comedy
from
commentary than we give them credit for
I think a lot of the angriest Among Us
are Amplified for the sake of clickbait
and I I don't think the the the actual
audiences are are quite as
representative
uh as of of that kind of noise as we
would we might be led to believe so uh
so and you know you look you do
screenings you have table reads you you
do test these jokes out to some degree
uh and if and then there are things that
get a gasp at the table read that don't
go in the show there are things that get
a laugh but you know you're on the edge
but people are still laughing so you
give them their shot uh but it is a
little different than if I were up there
with a microphone doing standup and I
made a joke and and I'm the face of it
and I'm the writer and I'm all alone so
here it's it's a group effort so it's
there is safety in numbers sure I was I
was sitting in a hospitality room
yesterday watching episodes and uh I was
laughing out loud where people were
looking at me and I just was was nice to
have jokes in a show that you know
pushed a little bit and were not just
safe you know yeah yeah yeah I I think
we I think we need that right now 100%
sir um is there a joke or is there an
episode or a scene in one of the
episodes you're like is this too far is
there something that even you said maybe
this is a little too much I mean it's
tough I don't I don't get mad when I see
things that cross the line in fiction
when I read the news you know and I see
anything with the phrase Texas Supreme
Court
then I get pissed then I get angry but
when I watch something that was that is
fiction written by writers for the most
part it doesn't I don't I I I make that
distinction so it doesn't rile me up so
I I don't I don't know there's nothing
that I can think of for me that in this
show that that uh that goes over the
line comedically something yeah I was
going to say when I was watching the
episode yesterday with uh something
about Vietnam I was I was there was a
joke with that that I was like oh this
is going anyway um so is if you get to
make a second season is it possible to
do a like modern story with wallberg in
an episode that then flashes back to the
Ted series does that make any sense that
you even think about doing something
like that yeah look anything is possible
the challenge with with Wahlberg is he's
he's very busy he's always working on a
movie or two or three and to get him for
a television series even for something
like Ted is the time commitment is is
oftentimes more than his schedule will
permit so uh if if he were to be
involved it would have to be in in in a
capacity similar to what you've just
described it it it hasn't been discussed
yet but anything is possible one of the
things I read that you guys originally
thought of doing this as a like a
multicam or it was a discussed possibly
as a multicam Allah and I was thinking
could that have been like an Al
situation where you know anyway could
you sort of talk about the the the
iterations and how you sort of got to
what people are saying yeah I I still am
intrigued by that idea the only reason I
didn't do it was that they wanted this
show
um as fast as they could get it and I
didn't want to go into a situation where
I was doing a multicam show with an
audience and a CGI character where I
didn't have time to to for R&D for
research and development to see if this
was even possible uh the reason that it
intrigued me was is that one of my
favorite Ted pieces of Ted footage is
his appearance on on Kimmel in uh in
2012 or 13 or whatever it was and it was
you know look film video nerds will know
what I'm talking about it was it was
that video you know what whatever is
3060 frames a second look as opposed to
film which gave him an immediacy that
he maybe didn't have at 24 frames a
second same thing when he and Mark were
at the Oscars he just feels maybe just a
little bit more real and I wanted to do
something like that the issue is you got
to shoot those things fast you got an
audience there waiting Y and um I I it
still intrigues me it's something that I
still would like to try at some point
because I think if it's I mean I mean
the idea of a CGI character there
waiting for an audience to finish their
laughter to before he says the next joke
the way an actor a live actor has to do
is is again it's yet another level of
reality I it's it's still kind of in the
back of my mind but we would need the
proper amount of time to really see if
it can be done because it could also be
a disaster oh 100% oh AB it could be
terrible um but it could be amazing yeah
yeah um so last time I spoke to Liam
niss uh he mentioned Naked Gun to me and
I'm gonna have to bring up naked gun
with you because he uh he seemed excited
and so what's the status of that it's
we're it's it's being uh it's being
worked on as we speak uh AKA schaer
who's who's uh written the draft with
his team has done a hell of a job and
and uh it's it is it is in development
so it is still very much alive awesome
to hear um we are now almost in 2024 as
a fan of your work I am curious what
you're thinking about doing next year
you know I I don't know yet I think by
January I'm going to have a a clearer
idea I I
this show was such an undertaking it was
so much work to to essentially do what
we
did in the films with the same quality
for
television uh that I'm I'm going to
Exhale a little bit over the month of
December and then when we get into
January I'll be kind of revved up and
ready to go again so I'm not sure there
there are a few things that are on the
table um a television project and a
couple of film projects and I I haven't
decided what's next on that note sir I
really want to say again thank you so
much for making me laugh have a
fantastic day thank you you
too